before we get to Reggie Miller McLovin
has a hot take not really that hot yeah
it is I'm telling you there's about 400
blogs on the ringer about this topic
that the Warriors are better without
Durant because they move the ball better
they look like the old Warriors as
compared to the 2016 Thunder with Durant
you said that the Warriors are
marginally better yeah there's a little
bit Durant in the liner yeah just a
little bit better especially in the
playoffs but during the regular season
they're about exactly the same the best
player in the NBA does not help his team
is what you say
yeah I'm not necessarily declaring mr.
strong the best player in okay one of
the top three players in the game top
five players doesn't help his okay you
don't mean though that he sucks the
energy out of that whole offense they
look like the Thunder let me bring in
Reggie Miller the hall-of-famer reg what
do you think of mclubbe and saw take
first of all what the heck is big loving
smoking is absolutely crazy
here's the thing in playoff basketball
and the reason why the Warriors look so
good during the regular season is it's
one game and you move on you're
traveling and you're on to the next city
on to the next team come playoff
basketball possessions and the game
slows down you get locked into a rhythm
so you've got to have players that can
create their own offense we saw that
case in point Damian Lillard game-winner
from 37-foot game-winner last night by
Kawhi Leonard game-winner by CJ McCollum
clear out one on one isolation
basketball you've got the best
one-on-one player in LA in my opinion in
Kevin Durant he absolutely makes the
Golden State Warriors unbelievably
difficult to defend come playoff
basketball yeah for a game we saw that
against the Houston Rockets in Game six
the old warriors and ball movement and
everyone contributed but every game
every situation is going to be different
and now that you're moving on the the
more you move on the better the teams
are defensively so you've got to have a
guy you can just throw the ball to on
the block
midrange and let him go to work and
that's what Kevin Durant brings McLovin
would you like to respond to Reggie
Miller yes what is Reggie no I mean but
what I will say is I don't think if the
Rockets first of all I can't believe the
the goofs job that they pulled in Game
six if they would have won Game six I
really would have thought they would
have won Game seven back in the bay area
without KD but look the Warriors found a
way to win that I think going forward
and I think the Warriors caught a break
they got a break by Portland winning
that series because if they would have
faced Denver with that movement with yo
kitch and those young players it would
have been a much I think it'll been a
much difficult series or Golden State to
win now they're almost playing like the
Rockets 2.0 again you've got two players
McCollum and Lillard 101 isolation
basketball right in front of you so
there's not a lot of movement like
Denver would have had the back cuts
Yogesh the passing the running the young
legs and on top of that going to mile
high in dealing with that I think it's a
much favorable matchup for Golden State
going against Portland Reggie will be on
the call in the eastern conference
finals along with Marv Albert and see
Webb before I get to some of these other
matchups here your thoughts with Frank
Vogel going to the Lakers I don't know
what the Lakers are doing seriously it
baffles me the first of all that you
would not offer
tyloo the five-year deal a guy with his
resume and he's earned that he's
deserved that
so there's a whole Jason Kidd thing what
are they doing never in the history of
head coaches has an organization told
you you've got to hire these assistant
coaches or this assistant coach it's
it's I'm not saying this but it's almost
like having a snitch in the huddle
basically that's what you're saying you
got to hire this guy but he'll report
because a head coach has to have total
confidence in his hit the rest of his
coaches and for an organization to pick
a coach for you I agree with tyloo kick
rocks I'm out so I'll I don't understand
what the Lakers are doing I really don't
I like Frank Vogel he coached my Pacers
he's a nice man but he's either a right
man for the Lakers or is it just Jason
Kidd's job in Waiting uh I don't
understand I don't understand what the
Lakers are doing does the right Rockets
does this system work as they go forward
or does harden and/or the Rockets need
to make an adjustment if they're gonna
win a championship and get by Golden
State no matter if KD is there or not
the system works during the regular
season yes because it's great you know
we talked about the one-on-one isolation
and it's one game and you're moving on
so teams don't prepare like they prepare
come playoff time so it's a great
regular-season offense that puts up
unbelievable numbers and mvp-type
numbers as we saw last year and
potentially this year for James Harden
but come playoff basketball you can't
play like that and it always it always
gets highlighted when you go against
Golden State because they expose you
defensively and offensively the things
that you need to do to be winners and
champions and once again the Rockets got
exposed by Golden State's at that system
the analytics threes versus twos and
mid-range you got exposed once again so
I don't know what changes they can do
your two main players that are eating up
the payroll in Chris Paul and James
Harden they're not going you can't trade
for them you know they make too much
money so I don't know what system
changes you can do unless they add
another a guy who can give them like a
mid-range jumper I just need to change
it up a little bit here I need another
kind they kind of think that was going
to be the case with Carmelo yes yeah
that's the beginning of next year that
was supposed to be their mid-range guy
yeah you know come playoff time you
thrown you know in that 15 to 18 foot
area and he could get you buckets but
that didn't work out
you're right they need a player like
that yeah it's a great point the calves
with John Beilein leaving Michigan to
coach that team your thoughts again
great man I love him
what are the Cavs doing I don't
understand and again look we're you and
I are all over the place with this this
is the problem with college basketball
because I don't know if you're gonna
find a better job
that Coach B line has in Michigan and I
believe because we covered them this
year in tournament they have a great
recruiting class coming in so what is
this saying to those kids what is it
saying to those guys that are staying
there III don't understand do they get a
chance to get out of there to get out of
there and go somewhere else someplace
right away no so why did he get rewarded
by jumping to the Cavs in a five-year
deal so I don't invest the problem with
college basketball
I love Coach B line a great coach I
think but what is he 65 66 taking the
Cavs job a pro job where he has zero
experience I believe I don't think he's
ever coached in the NBA but it's a great
opportunity for him in his family so I'm
you know that's the positive spin on it
but again what are they what are the
Cavs doing I don't know yeah I'm just
trying to I don't know if he's not
running away from something at Michigan
but you know you got to be running
towards something if you're gonna coach
in the NBA you got to be ready for that
and I know that he talked to Orlando in
Detroit and and maybe just started to
get a little bit more excited about that
possibility you know it's somebody who
knows him well emailed me to say you
know he's going tired of the college
basketball environment and the
recruiting and all of that 1% I get but
you're right about you have to be
running towards something Billy Donovan
two national championships at Florida he
was running towards Kevin Durant Russell
Westbrook I get that Fred Hoiberg
success at Iowa State but he was running
towards you know he was with Minnesota
for a long time as an administrator and
general manager and then running towards
that head coaching job with Chicago that
in a tractor job B line I mean you've
been to what back-to-back
for as I believe or success at Michigan
you're running towards the cab that's
what you're running for okay what's a
better job today
Cleveland or the Lakers it's still
Lakers obviously with LeBron come on
well you don't know what's gonna happen
tomorrow night in the lottery I have no
do you think the Lakers are gonna get
die on no no no Cleveland's gonna get
die on
well if they do I think I think
Cleveland's luck of number one picks is
about ready to run out okay I read
LeBron Bennett it's over but Brad just
be wrong I think it's over if Cleveland
wins New Yorkers getting that pick if
Cleveland wins the lottery what's a
better job on Wednesday the Lakers or
the Cavs steal the Lakers okay dying is
unproven as great as he is he's gonna
fill seats I get that but I still have
LeBron James no it's the Lakers I got
the bread okay I got the brand here was
one thing I was I was wondering and I
threw this out the other day and and
people aren't even it's not even
registering with them what if I said you
could have Blake Griffin's numbers
attached to Zion Williamson would you
sign up for that now that I mean it's 25
and 10 I feel like that people will be
disappointed if he's a 25 because if I
say oh he could be the next Blake
Griffin no we want him to be the next
Charles Barkley or LeBron James he might
be the next Blake Griffin reg I like
Blake's numbers nothing 25 in 10 gives
you buckets - I'll take Blake's game if
Diane Williamson at the end of his
career has Blake Griffin numbers and
game and can face you up they can knock
down threes and you can put them on the
block and the athleticism absolutely I
will take that people need to stop
because Charles was a freak of nature at
64 there will never be another Charles
Barkley at 6 more that can dominate a
game at that size rebounding block shots
handle a basketball and give you buckets
so to classify Zion
and Charles that's doing a disservice
but if he has Blake's numbers absolutely
a perennial all-star now he was the face
of the Clippers and now it's the face of
the Pistons and what he showed me
because we called that game him playing
hurt this dude to me goes to another
level man because he didn't have to play
in those two games with that Lake and
shouldn't have been playing but he saw
the writing on the wall and went out
there and gave it the old college try
and got a double-double versus in my
opinion calling it now possibly the
world champs in in Milwaukee his he goes
up another level and wait wait you got
Milwaukee you and Barkley got Milwaukee
winning at all the writing's on the wall
man they're deep and this dude a honest
man I want you guys to watch closely
because his eyes he has a tiger lion
look in his eyes on every player on
every possession on every play I'm
looking at everyone else's eyes maybe
Kevin Durant and Kawhi at times but this
dude is playing desperate and he doesn't
keep laying desperate and his team is
playing desperate and they're not hurt
they have depth they're well-coached
it's gonna take a long time to be able
to beat them I like but it's gonna take
a lot and especially I mean I call this
before the Kevin Durant injury just
because they have so many weapons I mean
he could play ten people and the way
that the Warriors were playing before
Durant Steve Kerr was only playing seven
guys and he was starting to Hamptons
five and they were all playing 36
minutes that's that's too many
that's too many so that's why you can
rest your guys in still advance that's
why Milwaukee in my opinion is gonna win
at all I I was dissecting the last play
with Kawhi and there were a couple
things that bothered me and you you were
there to see it but I can't let the best
player on the floor have the ball Reggie
and if I do let him have it
I got a double-team him so he gives
there's only four seconds left I I was
just kind of surprised at Philadelphia
they let him get it and then and he did
have to go a long way to get that shot
off but I can't let him get the shot off
okay did Cleveland not try to let
Michael Jordan Craig Ehlo them and Larry
Nance double-team you know they didn't
do a good job you got it okay but my
point is great players will find a way
to get the ball to the next try not to
let me get the ball with eight points in
nine seconds no no they they let you
find a way to get the ball wide Leonard
got the basketball with a 610 guy on him
and Ben Simmons drove past him
to pick up a 7 1 280 pound mobile big
red all I needed him to do is force him
left where there was a double-team I
would have said absolutely positively he
cannot go right that's it
not go right left you've got two guys
you got a double-team there and if
that's the case Philadelphia may be
playing in another series they may have
advanced because you force him left and
then you got a double-team he has to
give it up in it's four seconds left
it's simple it was a simple defensive
strategy but young inexperienced in that
situation no but you cannot say that's
terrible defense because he is dribbling
around a 610 guy and then he has to pick
up a 7 1 it picks up a 7 one guy a
couple of dribbles and shoots
unbelievable rainbow that has the touch
of death on it but you're we're looking
at the result we know the end result I
I'm saying in the moment doubling
doubling no no and then all of a sudden
he makes the shot which great players
will find a way to get about you can't
say double them because they forced him
into a double team Reggie I forced him
into the double team and then he gives
it up and then if Kyle Lowry beats me
than I live with it why didn't defender
run at Damian Lillard as he's walking
the ball up just to get the ball out of
his hands when CJ McCollum had it going
on and they drop to all 1/4
don't run at CJ McCollum bridge I should
be coaching I should be coaching the
Lakers well I didn't you know you should
be coaching the Cavs because you're
closer to Ohio and you're from Ohio you
should be the coach of the Cavs I passed
on that job reg they only gave me a
three-year appeal
that ain't right no player coach - hey
have fun in the East there with with
Marv and C Webb and take it in with you
guys on the road during the series this
is going to be funny go to be a fun
series think about this
Yanis on to to kupo versus Kwai Leonard
seriously does it get any better than
that
it does but you know we got the premier
series Thank You Jana versus Kawhi first
names only thank you rich thank you
that's Reggie Aloysius Miller junior the
third for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show at